معنى منك كيف مشاهدينا ايوري ساك مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني استاذ يورس ابدا من
الضربات الروسيه وعوده القصف الروسي على
المناطق الاوكرانيه من المعروف ان الروس
اليوم بحاجه لانتصار للداخل ولخارج هل هذه
الضربات يعني اتخلفت خسائر كبيره واين
تتركز
اليوم اخر يوم الاثنين حافل بطلقات من
صواريخ التي طالت مدن اخرىنيه وايضا ضربت
بنا تحتيه للطاقه بصوره عامه قام الروس
بشن اكثر من سبعه صواريخ اليوم والقوات
الدفاع الاوكرانيه استطاعت ان تسقط اكثر
70 صاروخا واسقطت قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه
60 منها
الاخيره التي سوف تقوم فيها روسيا بامطار
تلك الصواريخ وسوف نعمل على تحسين انظمه
الدفاعيه باستمرار وجع لي مدننا اكثر
امانه
الذي تسببت به القوات الروسيه كان قد لحق
همم مناطق بسيطه من الاهداف التي كانت
تعتزم روسيا اصابتها والضرر لم يكن كبيرا
لكن هناك بعض البن التحتيه الحيويه التي
تعرضت للاصابات وقوات الطوارئ
هناك عدد من القوات التي كانت تقاتل في
خرسان انتقلت اليوم الى الشرق الاكرانيا
هل انتقال هذه القوات مع قوات التعبئه
التي بدات تصل الى الجبهه ممكن ان تغير
المعادله في الشرق الاكراني وستتقدم
القوات الروسيه هناك
علينا ان نتذكر
ان خطوط التماس تبتسم بطبيعه دينميه
والقوات
هيئه القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تقوم
باتخاذ القرارات بناءا على ما تشهده ساحه
المعركه ونحن مستمرون في عمليتنا الهجوميه
المضاده واذا ما قررت هيئه الاركان بان
بعض الاماكن في الخطوط الاماميه تتطلب الى
اعداد المزيد الى عدد اضافيه من القوات
فسوف تعمل على ارسالها اننا متاكدونا في
الفتره الحاليه بانه هناك قتال مستعر حول
مدينه بخمس وبكل تاكيد
الدفع بهذه القوات سوف يقضي الى صد رد
القوات الروسيه وروسيا في حقائق للامر
تخسر الالاف من جنودها في مساء
كما ذكرتهم في معرض تقريركم بان الروس لم
يستطيع ان يحققوا اي نجاح عسكري ولهذا هم
مستمرون في ترويع الناس بطلقات الصواريخ
اسمح لي ان اتطرق الى موضوع التسريب
الامريكي بان البنتاجون عدل على صواريخ
نيمار كي لا تصل الى المناطق الروسيه
وبانه يعول على ان تحصل اكياس على صواريخ
بعيده المدى من طرف ثالث ما هو رد
اوكرانيا على هذا الموضوع خصوصا انكم
طلبتم اكثر من مره بهذه الصواريخ ومن هو
الطرف الثالث
بالتعليق على صواريخه مارس او اجرائها
ايتها هناك لقد قلنا في اكثر من مناسبه
انه كل ما زادت فعاليه
القواتنا اذا ما حصلنا على صواريخ التي
لديها قوه قوه
الناريه بمدى طويل وهذا يسهل علينا
استهداف العدو ولكن للاسف هذه قد تكون
محظو اشاعات ولا استطيع ان اقدم لك اي
تعليقات ذات مغزاء شكرا يا استاذ يوري ساك
مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني حدثتنا من
كاس